so I'm kinda if it you might not I'm
increasing them and so I decided to
create a light leader for you guys
basically show you a relative
to show your hockey news treatments the
very basics in equipment because I know
that so a lot of beginners we're going
to the games
it can be very scenario because you
might answer on what to do and we don't
have to work the muscles how to do
solicitor right now okay thank you
particularly some of the really basic
human right so when you answer instances
this is basically don't make
presentation okay the first thing when
you get on solution is always look out
for these signs alright so the first
picture will always tell you what
muscles you're working on supposed to be
look at the link press machine is
telling you that it's probably at least
ten strings and is in a quark okay and
the second picture will tell you the
fatty position and also the ending
position
so the seller position is your lakeside
degree and the ending position is having
your lake como straight all right so now
I'm going to hop onto the machine
okay so with the leg press machine the
first thing that you want to make sure
is know where to jump the fence is the
point where you can sell what we know
which is that on Christmas controller
depending on what we walk so you can I
am quite the city I encroached on so
what I'll do is I'll have to move
forward and I'll clear this up okay so
what you want to make sure is when you
click on the cob always make sure that I
play decrease so that's a completely new
kind of far away it is not my discrete
this is wrong all right to point out
when you go down and the server it is
slightly degree
and to the chest
all right the big alexei degree book
design as in if we talk mostly to follow
when you do have 2006 you okay balloon
fight
which is you all right
and make sure they are not locking your
knees so this is wrong key the meats off
really back down
who are you top three by self-control
limited role as Rebecca all right
the Oh implication that you laid the
close of my power and we are in a
nitrous to decline with age and we just
donate our big muscle when you can do
have increased away in Korea so for to
divide mission allegedly became back but
religion and immature through the venue
not lost
this is wrong remember we have a Duncan
Jones who we might notice negligence I'm
okay with lower than when you can show
your in taking amount of Capriccio which
up remember to use the build things up
and push it up alright if you want to
work we invite you tell your wider
relieve myself okay that wider because
use as well
great down focusing on invite you guys
down switch up and really back down okay
another thing you can use and to work on
this mission is basically of heart
muscle for your calf muscle and what it
does it is the gesture machine all the
way back they reduce the risk untii they
can hold let me know they make two
points up and what you can do is we're
going to come muscle to push it up with
the cop bring it back down push it up
with the cop we're back down up squeeze
down
all right so that's another way to do
the big drag the king because the really
focus on a cross
okay right now and let's go and work on
our back come on mm okay so same thing
again when you look at machines you
always want to look at the mission and
know what your what muscles you're
working on so basically it's telling you
that you're working on your what I like
to call it your wings
okay that's your back muscles and the
secondary muscles will be of high status
and also your triceps
so that's the starting position and
that's the ending position okay so this
is a lab food on machine so our product
is talking excitedly eventually
like asleep when you hold the white
upgrade you will be what he calls your
way
white
and
and what you
Oh
[Music]
a more
if you want to go get going and fight
back that'll be quite great
people to see more women
we died really slow and fluid as squeezy
Becca right you're back again remember
no hunting no a Latino being lazy no
doing this it always checked off who
works again alright and now it's finally
working for just another like that is
the never great spot we all day long
okay the creeps
this way we'll be back down so my can't
have faith in my face right now
same thing we need to catch up to it and
squeeze okay
not to speak of accent but we not into
object okay Latifah back plate we need
the Google 374 really and to like that
but okay some machines will have this
question if they treat works more okay
so what you want
right there my house my openly straight
I just still check out of that school
with the valley we can decide
[Music]
all right the origination always making
sure they're level and cochlea body
surrounded in with the elbows increasing
body using a new back no chicken wings
alike the relief and you don't you think
not
yo this is will not play no here right
now so difficult if you want to hold and
control
all right back don't like not be giving
back muscle by engaging all the house
alright what I get so this here is your
chest machine same thing again I just
want to show you how to look at the
machines alright so you have the picture
here showing you the major muscles
you're working on it's a chest a little
bit on your triceps and also your
shoulders okay this is the starting
position the ending position alright
with the chest muscles you want to go
slightly lighter so you're tracking a
bag it should be a loss in weight or
slightly lighter and back muscles so I'm
going to adjust it
that's an idiot might be right now okay
so when you sit on the custom suit
the first thing to make sure is that
your plot and go back okay it's truly a
game then let's see okay so no gap no do
they can I see it
this is wrong no no gap at all make sure
your box is fully linear density
the second thing to make sure is that
the handle near the bar here it should
be in line with the track okay but it
shouldn't be too low or too high right
now I do they play a little bit too high
what I'm going to do is I'm gonna jump
the sleep a little bit lower so right
now I can see that the bar near is
inviting my channel okay so go on to the
handle here the first thing you want to
make sure these make sure that your
elbows are not dropping or it is not too
high on the top there's likely changes
this is wrongish to the spring so much
video and will not be working on the
chest
Rebecca shoulder-width apart and when
you commit and give the occultation have
momentarily Siebert has applied again no
handsy give a chance of work quick slow
release lessor and with okay so before
hit something hit each other with the
back okay again remember this well blow
the door elbows you don't wanna be doing
this as well
it's the opposite okay so remember
people have those soft elbows up so that
we like create the chest muscles close
quick release control and squeeze okay
so do not defend your planet because
every movement is engaging a bottle as
well so will you put your ingredients at
when you can put and disease you
actually put your excitement and the
Spiritualist so again helps them to be
up against little Oh engage engage quit
and then
and push all right so that we'll be
working on each has muscle beginners
when you try this machine you might find
that you might be working on your
shoulders and it can always make sure
that you keep adjusting yourself and
really focus on this part here
eventually we work through that you're
moving more and it has and slightly back
and shoulders okay so this is a really
good technician really videocast and
also baby it works first half your
friend okay
right let's move on so this machine
right now they say they look at the
picture it's going to tell you the
muscles you're working on so it's
telling you that your major muscles are
your shoulder a little bit on your
triceps a smaller chain starting
position ending position remember that
for your shoulders your muscles are
really small so you want to start by
going tonight and going with let's say
ten students in English okay with the
shoulders machine when you wanna make
sure is that
depart the market a handle here is in
line with each other
so second you shouldn't be too low where
it's way higher in service is it wrong
or you shouldn't be too far off when
you're sure that it's about power to
make sure that it is be fine so so
yourself
take it up so it got me in line right
now and making sure that you thought you
said coolly leniency set against the
private a so simple and you start with
never greater all right this will be
easier and this will be slightly hollow
okay so in order you can recall roughly
about in the middle so same thing engage
the photo push it up all right all the
way up main thing with anyone else you
know essence or the joint so avoid
locking again if you become going back
down below push it up bring it back down
control push it up control down and
squeeze each other and it'll flow in
both Lance we do not want the spending
on Saturday remember
your shoulder muscle and small so when
you have the call 20 kilo of particular
for 20 or 30 of each others because they
are small to publish an affiliation 16
and 1 right
the slot machine right so this machine
dependency between one way to be safe
over when you will really gain check
bottles and it's right here okay and
also in this cardigan as well
the other way is to since they make it
fast
and holding their partner can be offered
in a civic idea which is when you sit
and face forward
these are the muscles you will be
engaging when it's it and face that
these are the muscles you will be
engaging okay you want to make sure that
your arms are straight in life so you
should be choosers you shouldn't be put
into fiber to make sure that every life
again making sure they're nice and
strong painting but fact community
my province see this forget it is for
visualizer me ok but one person is
making sure that your pelvis off the lot
you doubt yourself your choice of
release it to be on almost raised by
your elbows against none of them relief
and with the close release gently and
twist so do not over extend your wrist
your elbows this is what you're reading
a string of elders and your rep okay and
we do the exercises so just like my one
day off really focus and know which
month with your targeting so this
fishing right now it's my chance one
okay so I'm going to face backward when
you're worrying about what you've had it
just in fiber and bring it
and look like a double here okay
extended sweet testable we don't know
open please
and
yes right this is the ad machine again
when you look at the picture it's going
to tell you which muscles you're working
on this abdominal core muscles okay
starting position ending position
all right hook and we have we love them
so much
so we control since you all worked up
and control okay in conscious
legislation HR every movement ever
control your muscles you're engaging
even more muscles remember that okay
upwards downwards below whether is
contracting or releasing control
absolutely right just in case machine
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
before it won't be back
[Music]
and discreetly okay we're not living
you're not moving it I remember and we
should not be like so much not buildings
were completely is relaxed and disease
and for the bar one comfort any contract
release contract or we occupy that
really contract and release again there
you go
contract and release so this is what
you're not moving your path okay
as you know when you can or your body
this is wrong
see the body very skinny body straight
or you're going to moving your arm swing
back down and all right make a few of
the really basic gym equipment that I
like to use and for any beginner you can
try to use them
inaudible practice when you said use a
machine to begin with you might not
target the right approach for instance
when you work on the Catholic in you
might feel more initiative instead
attack it's all about being aware of
your body positioning little well what
muscles your key work on and really
treating your mind and really put it on
that much okay and so it's normal I can
work on a song so the game wins it is
very important to get us all right
before integrals really babies or before
uses it in to go really quick okay it's
not about speed it's about getting the
form right and then slowly increase the
weight so the gateways I would recommend
you to do 15 repetitions per exercise
and slowly increase the weight okay to
remember that these views the 50
repetitions and it is too easy you're
not doing anything you're not doing what
you're doing work out then you have to
increase the weight
don't go to light as well if you're
going to like that you're just wasting
your time and in this way represent them
to work in the last five repetitions you
should feel a slight struggle that's
when you know that they're really
working all of your muscles okay the
involve cluster with 50 refuses to
and that increases the way you can use
the resolution okay
so the next time we go into the gene I
don't need to student intimidated at all
by the machine I want you to go read the
pictures you will have your deposit give
it a try if you're unsure what you're
doing then watch this ask for container
trailer there will be more than happy to
help you if you do that any other
questions leave them in the comments
below and I will answer them right after
this
alright thank you so much for watching
this line tension between one more life
sessions to let me know what topics you
want to cover and I will aim to cover
them and I hope you have fun bye guys